Welcome back everyone this is going to be my new
game of thrones and house of the dragon video
there's a new comic con teaser trailer george
rr martin was also revealing more details about
the jon snow sequel so we'll break it all down
if you're brand new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the episodes i will be
doing full episodes for house of the dragon
just like i did for the main show as soon as
it premieres and as you saw during the teaser
trailer here we will be getting a bunch more
footage during their comic con panel this summer
and because there have been so many easter eggs
in the house of the dragon trailer for things that
you either see or hear about during the game
of thrones main show i will talk about those
speaking of familiar things i actually just
bought a replica the valyrian sword blackfyre
the ancestral blade of aegon the conqueror but it
hasn't arrived yet so i might just keep using long
claw like i used in my videos for the main show
aegon the conqueror is the aegon for which jon
snow was named aegon when he was born ned stark
gave him the name jon when he took him as a baby
from lyanna stark and because all bastards in the
north are called by the last name snow that's why
his name was jon snow in talking about house of
the dragon easter eggs because we're 200 years
earlier in the timeline the version of longclaw
that i used in my game of thrones videos for the
main series was the version that the old bear
gave to jon snow that was different from the
version of long claw that we'll see during house
of the dragon because longclaw was the ancestral
valyrian blade of house mormont on bear island
so it had been passed down with each generation
until it was given to the old bear jor mormont
the lord commander of the night's watch when jon
snow took the black and when he was using it
the hilton the pommel formed this ornate bear
for the sigil of house mormont that's why the
blade was named longclaw after a bear claw when
he gave it to jon snow he had the bear refashioned
into a white direwolf and it was thought of as
a wolf's claw like ghost's claw so he's still
wielding longclaw just a little bit different
from the original long claw but if it wasn't clear
because bloodlines were such a huge deal for the
targaryen family keeping their blood as pure
as possible jon snow is pretty much related to
all the targaryens that will meet during house
of the dragon just by nature of the fact that
they share targaryen dna and sister wiving was
a big deal within their family for a long time
we will make all the sister wiving jokes because
during the trailer we actually see the remarriage
of rhaenyra targaryen and damon targaryen her
uncle it's sort of like the converse of what
you saw during the game of thrones main show with
daenerys being jon snow's aunt it would have been
like them actually getting married and we told all
kinds of jokes about this when the main show was
happening but during the events of the series
daenerys never thinks of them being a couple
or getting married as being an issue even before
she married kyle droko she had actually grown up
assuming that she would marry her older
brother viserys just because that was such a
common practice in their family and they were the
only two known remaining targaryens at the time
that practice of marrying within the family isn't
the only thing that led to the classic targaryen
madness quote unquote that you hear about when
people talk about the targaryen temper or the
mad king's actual badness the reason why
the mad king became the mad king like went
mad was because of a couple events earlier
in his life that predated the original show
when he was born when he was younger even when he
took the throne he wasn't thought of as mad people
actually thought that he had a lot of potential as
a king but like when house of the dragon picks up
the king at the time is king viserys the first
daenerys older brother viserys is viserys iii
but the present day of the house of the dragon
show is meant to pick up a couple years before
like him being remarried during the trailer like
it seems like he's already remarried to allison
and she's already had a son with him his name
was actually aegon ii there were a lot of aegons
in the targaryen family just because aegon the
conqueror was so famous jon snow for example if
he'd taken the iron throne and actually become
king he would have been called aegon vi maester
aymon's younger brother actually did take the iron
throne and his name was aegon he became aegon v
people actually called him egg which maester
aemon referenced when he lay dying there's also
a prequel game of thrones show that they're
developing about a young aegon v called the
tales of dunkin egg based on the novella series
that george rr martin wrote but the events of
that series take place way later in the timeline
from when house of the dragon takes place and it's
meant to be a completely different thing make all
the jokes about iron thrones omelettes and broken
eggs broken aegons but we joke about there being
a lot of aegons in the targaryen family during the
trailer you see prince damon targaryen played by
matt smith getting remarried for the third time to
the older version of princess rhaenyra one of the
other sides one of the other factions in the dance
of the dragons they had a son later this year
that they got married and they named him aegon iii
right after queen allison just a couple years
previously had a son with the king viserys
named him aegon ii so it sounds like rhaenyra
and damon on the other side of this civil war
named their son aegon as well just out of spite
what they might do on the house of the dragon show
though is just push that pregnancy to like a later
season because it seems like their remarriage gets
depicted during the events of season one but their
son aegon iii was a full nine years old when the
actual dance of the dragon civil war started so
that just kind of gives you an idea for what the
timeline is like they will skip around in the
timeline a lot his cousin allison's son aegon
but like the throne looks way different than it
did during the original series like there's these
melted swords all around it harrenhal is probably
the best example of some of the biggest changes
this is meant to be a more book accurate version
of harrenhal than we saw on the main show with
all the melted stones it's meant to be the
largest castle in all of westeros like it's
massive compared to all the other castles but it
was built during the time of aegon the conqueror
by heron hoard that's why it's called harrenhal
and when he refused to bend the knee to aegon the
conqueror aegon took his three dragons including
bularian the black dread and burned harrenhal with
dragonfire it was so hot that it melted the rock
that's why the castle looked so melty thereafter
everyone just looked at the castle thinking of it
as a bad omen like when people were named lord of
harrenhal if it was given to them as a gift or
because of something great that they did it was
actually always thought of as an ill omen like
something bad is going to happen to you because
this seems more like a curse than a blessing so
that's why in present day no one really wants
to be the lord of harrenhal but basically what
they've done with the new house of the dragon
show is because special effects cg technology has
just gotten so much better since the main game of
thrones show started they just use their extra
money their extra tech to show you a much more
book accurate version of the castle it's the exact
same thing with the iron throne although this is
still a bit of a compromise and it looks more
like practical effects than cg effects but it
is closer to being book accurate on the main show
they didn't even bother with the melted swords in
the books the iron throne was made from the melted
swords of all the lords and the more powerful
figures around the six kingdoms who bent the knee
to aegon the conqueror he melted all the swords
down with valerian's dragon fire and that's why it
looks a little misshapen in the book there's this
really funny thing this rumor that goes around
the realm where people talk about people getting
cut by the actual iron throne when they sit on it
just because it's made of pointy swords of course
you're gonna get cut when you sit on it but also
there's the superstition that people who get cut
by the iron throne especially a lot are not meant
to sit on the throne joffrey for example terrible
king would cut himself all the time cersei cut
herself on the iron throne all the time it happens
to tons of people it's very common to cut yourself
when you sit on the iron throne the reason why
i made the comments about the six kingdoms is
because dorne didn't actually get conquered till
later in the timeline so technically was the six
kingdoms in dorne for a long time it wasn't till
king darren the first took the throne and he's the
direct grandson of damon and rhaenyra targaryen
almost 30 years after the events of the house
of the dragon when he took the iron throne he
conquered dorne and compelled them to join the
rest of the realms and westeros became known as
the seven kingdoms one of the other really big
things that they wanted you to pay attention
to in all the house of the dragon trailers was
the cat's paws valerian dagger being wielded by
queen allison everyone remembers it from the main
show it was the valyrian dagger that arya used to
kill the nike before that it was used in a plot
orchestrated by littlefinger to start the war of
the five kings it was a pretty elaborate plan too
and we theorized that before littlefinger came to
possess it it had belonged to jon snow's father
rhaegar targaryen because he loved collecting
things he loved reading scrolls about the long
night in the citadel they don't really give us any
more information about that during this trailer
all they're trying to show us is that hundreds
of years before he was born the dagger existed and
belonged to queen allison my early theory is that
it was given to her by king viserys after their
wedding like it might have just been part of the
valyrian weapons that belonged to house targaryen
in the crown at the time and he just gave it to
allison as a gift and then it just stayed in house
targaryen after the dance of the dragons was over
but speaking of similarities to the main show
talking about the game of thrones jon snow sequel
we just found out from george rr martin that the
working title is just snow that's what they're
calling it that's not what the actual show's name
is going to be they've just been in development
for a while and that's what they've been calling
it behind the scenes but apparently according to
george rr martin it also has been in development
for a couple years now like it's been going on
for a while now and news of it just leaked a
lot of people also believe george rr martin
kind of leaked the news accidentally himself
during an interview that he was doing recently
but regardless he just confirmed that it was a
real thing recently like yes this is happening
we are working on a jon snow sequel series i am
involved with it probably the most surprising
thing is that martin said that the idea for
the jon snow sequel came from kid harrington
himself and he had brought his own showrunner when
they were pitching it to hbo a couple years ago
and even though george rr martin had previously
said that he wasn't too keen on hbo telling
stories set after the end of the official song of
ice and fire ending of the main series he himself
did say that he was loosely involved with all this
but it was still in development so there's still
a long ways to go before it turns into actual
episodes so if you were confused george rr martin
for the most part is involved with all the game of
thrones sequels spin-offs anything related to game
of thrones hbo for the most part it's just that
he's more involved with the stuff that's actually